les cinq règles les cinq règles beaucoup
alors je vais vous donner les cinq
règles et Jean-Mi va rebondir là dessus
je prends
règle numéro 1 attention aux cuissons
oui beaucoup d'intoxication alimentaire
comme celle du à la truc à coller là je
sais pas quoi là non Michel Piccoli son
causés par la consommation de produits
animaux mal cuits ou consommés crus mais
aussi par des aliments soudés
un aliment cru un aliment cru un légume
mal lavé c'est potentiellement porteur
d'un germe donc il faut cuire les
aliments correctement et il faut laver
les fruits et les légumes alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les sushis les
sashimi et autres mais le sushi le riz
il a été cuit et le saumon effectivement
il y a un problème c'est pour ça que
dans les sushis mais ouais mais c'est
les sushis congelés ils posent moins de
problèmes que les autres parce qu'on
trouve pas le petit verre à l'intérieur
et bien sûr qu'avec les sushis il y a
des infections le poisson cru il y a des
infections bien sûr que ça peut faire il
faut parler aux poissons
sérieusement tant que tu manges des
sushis il faut que tu saches que dans le
restaurant où tu vas le type il est
précautionneux il y a eu plein de
magasins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors deuxième règle être vigilant sur
les animaux crus pour protéger les
enfants de moins de 5 ans plus
vulnérable il ne faut pas leur faire
consommer de lait cru une et de fromage
au lait cru ne pas leur faire boire
d'eau non traité venant depuis par
exemple avec les vaches vous moutons
chèvre et pour moi les américains ils
ont fait des ils refusent le lait cru
c'est uniquement parce qu'ils veulent
pasteuriser parce qu'ils veulent limiter
les risques c'est juste que ça nous on
s'accroche au lait cru parce que c'est
la tradition française du lait cru donc
c'est bon pour la santé mais c'est vrai
qu'il est très pose un risque ah oui le
lait cru prend un penderie c'est la
raison et le lait cru on vous retrouve
partout partout dans le hachis
parmentier
au moins contrairement à vous hein voilà
qui mettait les pieds sous la table
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les intoxications qu'il y avait eu à la
viande hachée à un moment donné on s'est
rendu compte que c'était les ouvriers
qui travaillaient dans les abattoirs en
fait ils allaient aux toilettes puis ils
ont enlevaient pas les gants pour aller
plus vite il revenaient des toilettes et
comme ils avaient les gants ils
manipulent la viande et ben bien sûr
il suffit de la poignée de la porte
alors je vous le dis
le caca est partout sur le téléphone il
est sur vos lacets il est il est sur
votre braguette le caca est partout on
en viendra tout ça
j'avais un ami qui bossait dans une
grande marque de de glace et en fait
leur grand jeu au salarié c'est d'aller
faire caca dans les grandes cuves bien
sûr dans les grandes cubes de de glace
et en fait le patron en fait est obligé
de faire des contrôles toutes les
semaines et il voyait du caca dans la
glace et oui bah oui bah parce qu'il y
avait du caca
pingouin et apparemment apparemment dans
les grandes usines quand il y a des
problèmes apparemment il y a des ils se
vengent souvent sur les aliments donc
bah oui docteur c'est la vérité comme
les restaurateurs quand ils veulent se
venger d'un client il crache dans le
sang
heureusement c'est rare
chacun
de la vérité moi hier j'ai mangé une
pizza
une marguerite
il faut bien conserver ses aliments on
cerveau frais les produits traiteurs
pour la cuisine et pâtisserie et on les
consomme 3 jours max après leur achat 3
jours max oui madame il y a une machine
non pas du tout c'est très sincèrement
malheureusement
toutes les dames achètent ça qui
aspirent le c'est bien ce truc là qui
aspire les produits
une machine avec deux feuilles plastique
et en fait vous mettez vos aliments et
ça
moi j'ai fait pareil avec mon sexe et
il est parti avec le plastique
d'ailleurs je remplace Simon regarde ce
soir un petit conseil pratique
simplement c'est que on oublie de
nettoyer les réfrigérateurs
des yaourts enlève le carton mais les
yaourts mais les yaourts dans le covid
on était très propre pendant énormément
les Chéries et puis bien entendu le 1
c'est le frigo comme vous l'avez dit il
faut le soigner vous l'avez dit faut
nettoyer régulièrement son réfrigérateur
moi je le trouve bien sûr